[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing Lord
Voldemort and the Death Eaters now we
know the Death Eaters as Lord
Voldemort's loyal followers they bear
the dark mark and when the curse more
Mort is cast the dark mark symbol is
projected into the sky a symbol that
incites fear in the hearts of many from
the Goblet of Fire he realized that it
was a colossal skull composed of what
looked like emerald stars with a serpent
protruding from its mouth like a tongue
as they watched it rose higher and
higher blazing in a haze of greenish
smoke itched against the black sky like
a new constellation Arthur Weasley
expresses his fear of this symbol in the
Goblet of Fire you-know-who and his
followers sent the dark mark into the
air whenever they killed of the terror
it inspired you have no idea you're too
young just picture coming home and
finding the dark mark hovering of your
house and knowing what you're about to
find inside everyone's worst fear the
very worst now we know that when
Voldemort was just a boy at school he
was in Slytherin house and it was here
that he formed a gang of fellow
Slytherin students Dumbledore described
little skank as a mixture of the weak
seeking protection the ambitious seeking
glory and the thuggish seeking a leader
who could show them more refined cruelty
it was these same students that are
considered to be the forerunners to what
would become the Death Eaters that we
see later on in the books and films
Death Eaters are pureblood radical
supremacists the cast unforgivable
curses without remorse and torture
muggles half-bloods and blood traitors
alike one thing that I always found
interesting was that the Death Eaters
were purebloods seemingly hell-bent on
achieving pureblood supremacy but right
at the top of their organization there
was a half-blood Lord Voldemort The
Death Eaters always seemed so proud of
their pure magical bloodlines so isn't
it ironic that their leader the Dark
Lord Himself was a filthy half-blood
maybe they just didn't know in the
Goblet of Fire
Voldemort addresses all of the Death
Eaters in a long
in his monologue he discusses his need
to acquire his father's bone to
regenerate and the necessity to travel
to little angleton where his grave was
located the books imply repeatedly that
little Angleton is a small muggle
community which is definitely not a
place that a pureblood family would live
in little Hangul tton Voldemort's
father's gravestone also clearly reads
riddle so if the Death Eaters didn't
already know that Voldemort was a
half-blood this would have been a dead
giveaway as they would have been easily
able to recognize that riddle
was not the name of a known pureblood
family so if the Death Eaters are so
intent on pure blood supremacy and
ridding the world or dominating over
half-bloods and muggles isn't it unusual
that the very man that they follow is a
half-blood what's their angle why do
they follow him the main goal of the
Death Eaters was to purify the Wizarding
community by eliminating wizards and
witches born to non-magical parents
Voldemort wanted the same thing but he
also wanted to establish himself as a
powerful overlord possessing the desire
to have the Wizarding World rule of all
muggles of all the most objective was
actually quite similar to Grindelwald
who wanted to break down the divide
between muggles and wizards and
effectively have wizards rule over
muggles for the greater good so the
goals of the Death Eaters and Voldemort
are basically in alignment
but this also begs the question why
follow one dark wizard if the Death
Eaters are the pure blood descendants of
powerful Wizarding families shouldn't
they be able to take things into their
own hands why follow a half-blood there
are actually a lot of reasons for this
the first reason is that because they
know Voldemort to be powerful himself
and because they have an overinflated
sense of how powerful pure Bloods are
when in reality it doesn't make a
difference they assumed that their side
will eventually be victorious over the
good side they are ignorant ly confident
that Voldemort will win based on his
power and history and they just want to
be on the winning side next they're
blind because they have such a deep lust
for power following and serving one man
who they are confident will be
victorious it's much better to them than
continuing with the current world
hierarchy in which they are not
necessarily anywhere near the top of the
food chain
then the alternative to following Lord
Voldemort would be to lead an
unfulfilled life next many of them have
weak personalities and are swayed easily
Dumbledore puts it nicely they are the
weak seeking protection often weaker
personalities are easily swayed by a
charismatic leader which Voldemort
certainly was a perfect example of this
is Peter Pettigrew
next a lot of the magis generally evil
and are just glad to have the
opportunity to follow someone who
enables their evil inclinations to be
expressed these people fit Dumbledore's
description of the thuggish seeking a
leader who could show them or refined
cruelty and lastly some Death Eaters are
just afraid of falled world and follow
him because they don't know how to say
no to him but also just don't have
enough confidence in the good guys to
follow them either Igor Karkaroff and
lucius malfoy later on in the books are
good examples of this and that's it for
this video why do you guys think the
Death Eaters follow Lord Voldemort if
you enjoy the content please remember to
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time you're a wizard
Ari
[Music]